[Música]
las autoridades prorusas instaron a los
habitantes de gerson a evacuar la ciudad
de inmediato las evacuaciones
organizadas por las fuerzas de Moscú que
controlan la región llegan en medio del
avance de la contraofensiva de kiev y de
las tensiones en La Represa del río
nieper que de ser atacada inundaría la
zona
Georgia melón y juró el cargo de primera
ministra de Italia su mandato supone el
regreso de la extrema derecha al poder
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial melón y
ya presentó su ejecutivo Tenemos reporte
desde Roma
en China concluyó el vigésimo congreso
del partido comunista la renovación del
comité central podría afianzar al
presidente en el poder y asegurarle un
tercer mandato al frente del gigante
asiático tenemos
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania las
autoridades prorrusas de gerson región
anexada ilegalmente a Moscú pidieron a
los ciudadanos que evacuen la zona de
inmediato sin embargo las evacuaciones
empezaron el miércoles y ya más de
25.000 residentes han sido trasladados
según las autoridades regionales
oficialmente las fuerzas rusas dieron la
orden de agilizar las salidas civiles de
gerson por la amenaza de un bombardeo
masivo sobre la ciudad recordemos que
esta es la única gran urbe a manos de
Moscú y que el ejército ucraniano la
podría intentar recuperar en el marco de
su contraofensiva
continúa las evacuaciones en gerson con
pocas pertenencias y mucho temor miles
de residentes de esta ciudad del Sur
soberanía huyen desesperados el ejército
ruso los instó a abandonar sus hogares
Durante los próximos días se espera que
el ejército de kiev realice una
contraofensiva para recuperar el terreno
anexionado por Moscú alrededor de 10
autobuses transportaban refugiados hoy
ayudamos tanto como pudimos movimos
cosas algunos fueron transportados en
minibús a la ciudad otros fueron
escoltados a estaciones suburbanas
Rusia planeaba actuar entre 50.000 y
60.000 personas de la urbe la cual tenía
unos 284 mil habitantes antes de ser
invadida por los rusos al principio de
la guerra Esta es una zona de alto
interés para ambos lados del conflicto
se trata de un objetivo principal debido
a sus industrias clave y Su importante
Puerto fluyal Durante los últimos días
gerson ha sido testigo de fuertes
enfrentamientos alrededor de 2.000
reclutas rusos han llegado a la ciudad
mientras las fuerzas ucranianas
continúan aumentando la presión en la
región
nos ofrecieron salir debido a la difícil
situación recibimos mensajes de texto
no tomamos una decisión de inmediato
pero luego nuestros amigos y familiares
nos invitaron y ahora nos vamos a Moscú
esperamos tiempos mejores y queremos
volver a nuestro jezón natal yo anduvos
entre tanto Ucrania pidió el viernes una
misión de observación internacional en
la presa de jacobka kiefa acusa a Moscú
de preparar ataques que inundarían una
vasta zona del Sur ucraniano
continuamos con más información
relacionada con la guerra porque este
sábado Ucrania denunció nuevos ataques
rusos contra infraestructuras
energéticas en el oeste del país varias
regiones por ello reportaron cortes
eléctricos los ataques se dan después de
que el ministro de energía ucraniano
confirmara ayer que las embestidas rusas
han mermado la capacidad de generación
térmica del país a la mitad por otro
lado continúan las tensiones alrededor
de La Represa de Nova kakova en el río
nyaper que de ser atacada inundaría la
región de gerson kiev acusa a Moscú de
haber minado la infraestructura para
impedir El Avance de las tropas
ucranianas en el marco de su
contraofensiva acusaciones que el
kremlin rechaza y de hecho el ejército
ruso aseguró que hoy repeló varios
ataques ucranianos en las zonas que
controla
el enemigo intentó romper las defensas
de las tropas rusas enviando hasta dos
grupos tácticos de Batallón lanzados
hacia los asentamientos de piaticati su
hannover Sabrok y en el lado oeste del
Río nieper en la región de gerson todos
los ataques fueron rechazados el enemigo
fue empujado a sus posiciones iniciales
y este sábado la agencia Estatal de
noticias de Irán reportó que las
autoridades de Teherán condenan las
peticiones de Francia Alemania y Reino
Unido que pidieron a la ONU Investigar
si Rusia usa drones iraníes en la guerra
en Ucrania la polémica gira en torno a
los llamades drones kamikaze que Rusia
está usando contra zonas civiles en
regiones como kiev Estas armas explotan
al impactar contra los objetivos y por
su corta altitud de vuelo son difíciles
de alcanzar por los sistemas de defensa
antiaérea
cambiamos ahora de información porque la
ultraderechista Georgia melonium juró el
cargo de primera ministra de Italia se
convierte así en la primera mujer en
ocupar el cargo a la vez que su mandato
implica el regreso de la extrema derecha
al poder desde la caída del régimen de
Benito Mussolini nuestra corresponsal en
Roma Natalia Mendoza tiene todos los
detalles sobre la conformación del nuevo
ejecutivo
a menos de un mes de las últimas
elecciones legislativas en Italia este
sábado se llevó a cabo el juramento del
nuevo gobierno italiano Georgia melón y
la líder del partido de ultraderecha
posfacista hermanos de Italia da así
inicio a su mandato junto con un
gabinete de 24 ministros 18 hombres y
seis mujeres entre los que se destacan
Antonio taiani ex presidente del
parlamento europeo nombrado canciller y
Vice Primer Ministro también Mateo
salvín y líder del partido de
ultraderecha la liga nombrado vicepre
Primer Ministro y ministro de
infraestructuras otro dirigente de la
liga Giancarlo georgetti estará al
frente del Ministerio de economía se
trata del gobierno más derechista en
Italia desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
Georgia melón y nacida en Roma hace 45
años se convierte en la primera mujer al
poder en la historia democrática de
Italia deberá afrontar numerosos
desafíos el control de las finanzas
públicas en un país profundamente
endeudado la lucha contra el desempleo y
la administración del fondo de
recuperación europeo Italia es el estado
que más dinero europeo va a recibir unos
200 mil millones de euros en préstamos y
subvenciones otorgados a Italia por
parte de la Unión Europea a cambio de
llevar a cabo un programa ambicioso de
reformas
repasemos ahora el contexto político
italiano en el siguiente informe del
laurel
el nuevo gobierno de Italia será
recordado por ser la administración más
conservadora desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y la victoria de la coalición de
la derecha en los comicios legislativos
del 25 de septiembre no solo hizo
triunfar a Georgia meloni con su partido
los hermanos de Italia como el más
votado que ahora asumirá el cargo de
primera ministrar el país después de los
comicios las cámaras del parlamento
también eligieron a dos presidentes con
valores ultraconservadoras
primero el senador la cámara alta eligió
a Ignacio la rusa como su líder
cofundador de los hermanos de Italia con
melón y este siciliano de 75 años ha
sido un activista de la extrema derecha
durante toda su vida antiguo ministro de
defensa de berlusconi la rusa es También
conocido por coleccionar recuerdos
fascistas y al día siguiente la cámara
baja de diputados dominó a lo Renzo
Fontana como presidente un estrecho
Aliado de salvini y devoto católico
conocido por sus posiciones antioborto
contra el matrimonio homosexual y por
sus comentarios amistosos con la Rusia
de Vladimir putino a pesar del perfil
mayoritariamente conservador de este
nuevo parlamento italiano ya se han
observado tensiones dentro de la
coalición gubernamental con los partidos
de Silvio berlusconi y Mateo salvini
negándose a desaparecer detrás de
Georgia meloni una nueva administración
que llega además en un contexto de
desafíos para la tercera economía de la
zona Euro incluida una deuda que ha
alcanzado el 150% de su pib una recesión
inminente y precios récord en la energía
provocados por la Guerra de Ucrania
y en China se clausuró el vigésimo
congreso del partido comunista con la
elección de un nuevo comité central del
que saldrán el nuevo politburo y un
nuevo comité permanente del partido tras
los cambios en este congreso se espera
que la actual mandatario
afiance su poder al frente de la
formación que dirige el gigante asiático
asegurándose un inédito tercer mandato
los detalles los trae desde Beijing
nuestro corresponsal Adrián foncillas
ha terminado esta mañana el congreso del
partido comunista con la previsible
aprobación de las enmiendas que dan
todavía más poder así sin pinta me ha
servido para que fuera nombrados los 200
miembros del nuevo comité central que a
la vez mañana elegirán a los 25 del
polípruro y a los siete del comité
permanente y con la lista del comité
central ya podemos adelantar algunos
puntos no estarán como la previsible dos
miembros que han superado ya la edad
oficiosa de jubilación pero tampoco
otros dos que no lo habían superado
hablamos del Primer Ministro lique Chan
y de One yang que precisamente sonaba
como su sustituto esas cuatro vacantes
dan un amplio margen de maniobras y sin
pin para que moldee el principal órgano
de gobierno y lo llene de acólitos la
imagen del Congreso había llegado unos
minutos antes de la votación cuando un
bedel pidió al expresidente a wishington
sentado a la izquierda de si que se
levantará y abandonará la sala lo ha
hecho finalmente después de resistirse
en una escena que ha dado pábulo a todo
tipo de especulaciones quizá se debió a
que Ju se sintió indispuesto y que
recordar que tiene 79 años y que se
había visto muy desmejorado durante la
semana O quizá fue la escenificación de
una purga sería una maniobra inédita
porque nunca se había actuado contra un
expresidente y porque estas Este tipo de
purgas exigen de un proceso judicial
previo menos sorprendente ha sido que el
partido incluyera en la Constitución su
oposición a la independencia de Taiwán
pasamos ahora a Reino Unido porque el ex
Primer Ministro británico Boris Johnson
aterrizó en Londres tras unas vacaciones
en el Caribe Johnson llegó al aeropuerto
de gatwitch desde República Dominicana
su llegada refuerza las especulaciones
sobre sus intenciones de anunciar una
candidatura para regresar a Downey
Street de dónde salió recordemos tras el
escándalo del partigate los aspirantes a
reemplazar a la fugaz listas Tienen
hasta las 2 de la tarde del lunes hora
local para reunir el apoyo de al menos
100 parlamentarios conservadores según
las reglas establecidas por el poderoso
comité
1922 Dado que los Stories tienen
357 diputados solo se podrán presentar
tres aspirantes de momento solo el ex
ministro de finanzas rishizunak cuenta
con los avales necesarios y solo la
líder de los Stories en la cámara de los
comunes Penny morton ha confirmado sus
intenciones de conseguir el cargo
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos porque A
pocas semanas de las elecciones de medio
término en el país el comité que
Investiga la toma del Capitolio del 6 de
enero de 2021 citó formalmente al ex
presidente Donald Trump para declarar y
presentar documentos mientras se
comunicaba la orden uno de sus ex
asesores fue condenado a prisión por
desacato Andrés triviño tiene los
detalles
un nuevo golpe para Donald Trump el
expresidente de Estados Unidos Fue
citado este viernes por el comité de
representantes para declarar sobre el
ataque del 6 de enero de 2021 al
Capitolio y le pidió proporcionar una
serie de documentos que van desde
comunicaciones personales entre el
republicano y miembros del Congreso
hasta información sobre sus contactos
con grupos extremistas en virtud de una
votación unánime el comité selecto
emitió una citación al expresidente
Donald Trump para que brinde testimonio
y registros relevantes para la
investigación del comité selecto sobre
el ataque del 6 de enero al Capitolio de
los Estados Unidos y sus causas Trump
deberá presentarse al Capitolio en
persona o en videoconferencia a partir
del 14 de noviembre y de ser necesario
durante varios días el comité también
señaló que los documentos deben ser
presentados antes del 4 de noviembre y
hasta el momento no está claro si el ex
mandatario aceptará la citación paralelo
a la orden de citación Steve banon uno
de los antiguos los profesores del ex
presidente fue sentenciado a cuatro
meses de prisión y Apagar 6.500 dólares
por no acudir a declarar sobre el mismo
caso ante el comité
tendremos un proceso de apelación
vigoroso para esta decisión tenga un
gran equipo legal y habrá múltiples
áreas de apelación Pero como dice ese
letrero a la derecha ahí podemos tener
el letrero de Voto el 8 de noviembre van
a tener un juicio sobre el régimen
ilegítimo de bailen
habrá que ver si estos nuevos hechos
influirán en los resultados de las
elecciones de medio término en las
cuales los estadounidenses decidirán si
mantienen en El poder del Congreso a los
demócratas o si los republicanos podrán
tener más protagonismo
y con este reporte que sin duda marcará
la campaña de Cara a las elecciones de
medio término en noviembre en Estados
Unidos cerramos esta edición pero ya
saben que pueden ampliar toda esta y más
información en nuestras redes sociales
en nuestra página web Franz 24.com Y por
supuesto aquí en directo en nuestra
cadena sigan con nosotros en seguida
volvemos
[Música]